so about two weeks ago the alphago team
by google deepmind they published their
latest paper in the alphago series this
time it's called alphago zero and I want
to dive into some of the technical
details that make this version of
alphago so much better than the previous
version that beat lee sedol you ready to
dive in deep my name is Andrew and
welcome to archive insights so I want to
go over five of the main changes that
were implemented in the latest alphago P
so the first thing is that in comparison
with the previous version
alphago zero trains entirely from
self-blame that means that it does not
use any datasets from human professional
goal players it learns the game of go
entirely from scratch using only
sethbling the second thing is that the
previous version used a lot of
predefined features that were
handcrafted for the game of gold the new
network alphago 0 uses none of those
features and learns entirely by
observing the board state another
interesting thing for me is that they
change from a normal convolutional
architecture based on inception to a
completely residual architecture I guess
ResNet is here to stay
another major tweak to the network is
that instead of having a separate policy
and evaluation network the two are now
combined into a single large network
that does both of these things and then
finally they replaced the Montecarlo
rollouts with a simpler two research
approach that uses this single network
to both do value prediction and to come
up with very strong moves so let's go
over all of those tweaks one by one so
we start out with a board position in
the game of gold the game of go consists
of a 19 by 19 grid so you have 19 by 19
squares every single one of them
containing either a white stone a black
stone or nothing at all what they
decided to do is they create a separate
feature map for the white stones and for
the black stones so that means that for
all of the white pieces on the board you
have a 19
by nineteen binary matrix which just
says a1 whenever there is a white piece
on that position and is zero when there
is not a white piece there in the black
feature map you do the same thing a 1
whenever there's a black stone any zero
and there's nothing anyway now instead
of simply having those two planes that
actually represents the current position
of the board they also include seven
other feature planes which represent the
seven past board States so they include
a little bit of a history of the game
inside in these board representation I
was kind of surprised as to why they did
this so I asked the question on their
Q&A on reddit and the reply I've had is
that this history actually acts as some
kind of an attention mechanism so if you
also include the past moves of your
opponent then your network can actually
focus on what the reporting was playing
and this works as some kind of an
attention mechanisms are kind of
interesting additionally there are also
some ghosts specific rules that require
you to take into account the recent
history in order to play moves that are
allowed by the game so we end up with
this 19 by 19 by 16 board representation
eight feature maps with the white stones
and eight feature map for the black
stones all of which are binary numbers
either 1 or 0 and then in order to play
the game you need one final thing you
need to know whose move it is is it
White's move or is it black speed and so
for this in theory you only need a
single bit but the google deepmind team
they actually decided to duplicate this
bit and to actually duplicated over the
entire 19 by 19 grid the reason for this
is mainly an implementation detail
because if you want to feed this whole
representation 19 by 19 by 17 to a
convolutional network it's easier if you
can just duplicate that last bit over
the entire future frame so we take this
input board representation and then
we're going to feed it to the network so
the previous version of alphago actually
used a standard convolutional
architecture
whereas this new version of alpha by 0
they replace the standard convolutions
with the residual network so that means
that in every single layer there is
actually a pathway from the input
directly to the output without any
convolutions being applied to it and the
major reason why residual connections
not to work so well is because they
allow the gradient signal that is used
for training this network to actually
pass straight through the layers so if
you are early on in your network
training process and your convolutional
network is not really doing anything
useful yet you can still allow your
useful learning signals to pass through
those layers in order to fine tune other
layers so we take our board's
representation run it through the
residual network and then we end up with
this feature vector and now from this
feature vector we need to create two
things the first thing they create is
the value representation this is simply
a number between 0 & 1 that represents
how certain the alphago network is that
it is going to win the current game the
second part of the network output is the
policy vector and this is actually a
probability distribution over all the
possible moves that alphago can play
given the current position and obviously
we want to train our system to play very
good moves so the whole board
representation actually needs to lead to
high probabilities of good moves and low
probabilities of very bad moves that is
the whole goal of training the system ok
so now that we've looked at the network
architecture going from a board
representation through the residual
connections onto a value representation
and in policy vector how do we train
this thing if we look at the version of
alphago the beat lee sedol
this version was actually trained in two
stages the first stage used supervised
learning on a data set of professional
go moves whereas the second stage kind
of fine-tune that pre trained network
using self play the new version of
alphago zero uses no data set whatsoever
it does not use any professional
gameplay from humans it learns entirely
by self play and for people who have a
little bit of a background in
reinforcement learning this might sound
very surprising because many of you will
know that if you train a network using
only self play your network becomes very
very unstable this was actually the top
question on the reddit Q&A and the
answer the alphago deep mine team gave
is that it is actually the Monte Carlo
tree search that stabilizes the self
weight training process so well so the
training stage goes as follows you get a
board representation you run it through
your net
which will initially contain random
weights and you get this output let's
look at the policy vector in the
beginning this policy vector will be
random so what you do is you select a
bunch of these possible moves and you
select the ones that have the highest
probability so you're gonna assume that
the ones that have high probabilities
are also potentially the strongest moves
you select those moves and then based on
those moves you get a bunch of different
game states because you're going to play
each and every single one of those moves
from your top policy vector results and
you're going to actually simulate
playing those moves you end up with a
bunch of new board states and then for
every single one of those board states
you're going to repeat the process and
so in the end what ends up happening is
that your current board position that
you're evaluating is actually going to
explode into this gigantic tree of
possible board states that's going to
expand and expand as you run through
more and more simulations and the idea
is that if you explode this search tree
you can go on to a certain depth because
obviously the explosion is going to be
exponential and you are limited by the
computational power of your
infrastructure
so the alphago team they decided to play
about 1,600 simulations for every single
board evaluation so that means that for
every single board state you're gonna
run the Monte Carlo tree search until
you have exactly 1,600 simulations and
at that point we're going to use your
value network so the value network is
going to decide okay which of these
board positions are actually good ones
which ones am i potentially going to win
and then you can back up all those
values all the way up to the top of your
network and then you have this very
solid estimate of which moves are strong
and which moves are not so strong and to
give you an example of this they
included a very interesting graph in the
paper which shows you the performance of
the alphago Network in different
versions so you can see the light blue
color is the alphago version that won
against Lisa doll but then the
interesting thing is the the lower bar
on the left side the gray bar because
that one actually represents the e low
strength of the network without using
Monte Carlo tree search so if you were
to take the network as it is trained
fully trained
but you're only using it once so you
took a board position you run it through
the network and then you select the
single best move from that policy vector
without doing any one to call it
research you end up with the strength
that you see there in the graph so even
though we deep learning enthusiasts
might think that this is a great victory
for deep learning I think we should keep
in the back of our minds that raw
computational force by actually using a
lot of those simulated board states is
still a very big part of the solution an
additional note to that is that this
procedure is very specific to a game
like go where you have perfect
information games and you also have a
perfect simulator because in this case
in the game of Go you can select a
potential move and then you can simulate
everything that would happen down that
path in the search tree but in the real
world that is usually not possible so
having a perfect simulator in this case
is a very very big advantage that you
normally wouldn't have in the real world
and let's take a look at some graphs in
the paper here you can see the training
procedure of the alphago 0 network when
compared to a purely supervised learning
approach and what is very interesting to
me is for example the middle one it
shows you the prediction accuracy that
the network has on a data set of
professional moves so it turns out that
you can actually see in this graph that
alphago plays the game of gold
differently than a human professional
work but also noting Li if you look at
the right graph you can definitely see
that the Alpha by 0 network is much
better at predicting the outcome of the
game you know whose side is going to win
by the black based on a current board
position and this graph is also very
interesting because it shows you what
the effects are of transitioning from a
normal convolutional architecture to
residual network so the if you look at
the left graph the blue the blue bottom
bar on the right side is the original
network that we
in the previous version and then the red
one is actually where they combine both
the policy vector and the value
representation in a single network using
only the same convolutional stack so you
can see a major improvement in evil
rating there the same improvement or
almost the same improvement is made when
you go from the original paper to a
residual architecture so by just
switching out the normal convolutions
with residual connections you actually
get a very strong improvement as well
and then if you combine the two in a
single network both using residual
connections and using the combination of
value representation and policy vector
then you get the purple bar which is the
final system and then to finalize here
this is very interesting graph as well
it shows you a couple of the very known
moves in the game of Go so the game of
Go has been you know it's been around
for thousands of years and there are
some very strong potential moves that
are known and things like you know the
Knights move or one space jump or a 3/3
invasion these things they have gotten
names because they are very known and
strong tactics and you can see for some
of them that alphago actually discovers
them using only self play but then after
a while it figures out stronger tactics
and it doesn't use these as much anymore
so kind of interesting to see that right
so that was my take on the alphago zero
paper amazing results from the google
deepmind team I hope you all learned
something if there are questions that I
didn't address please post them in the
comments down below and I hope to see
you next time in the next episode of
archive insights
[Music]